hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and
today I am watching Cat in the Hat this
is the first week of November where I
watched terrible terrible films and I'm
starting it off with just a my classic
what a what a classic I don't want to
watch last week was technically in
November although I was still calling it
Tam Tober fest but it was the human
centipede so it could also fit right in
there I've heard from the nostalgia
critic guys that this is just terrible
Wilson Wilson let's see if it's that bad
I think it will be I like Mike Myers
though so I don't know there should be
some comedy there I like Dakota Fanning
third example Oh God okay let's just do
it you know I mean all right
[Music]
well that was a pit of sadness that I
will never recover from
there was no laughter there was just cat
there were no smiles to be had there was
just hat there was no joy there was only
Mike Myers being terrible well how are
you so bad in a film and then so good
and so many other things what what I was
texting Doug and Rob Walker about my
movie-watching experience with this and
I said I didn't even smile let alone
laugh there was no joy to be found in
this movie end quote by Tamra chambers I
think this is one of the worst films
I've ever seen
the lack of comedy was insane the lack
of fun was insane literally not once did
I smile from something just like vaguely
making me happy it was so so so so so so
bad oh how did they make it that bad
when the source material is so good and
Edwin oh stop laughing at yourself I do
this all the time in my cameras they
receive episodes all like say something
and then I'll laugh and one of editing
back I'm like wow you really laugh at
yourself a lot of camera this no no Mike
Meyers as cats stop laughing at yourself
here's a dumb joke that I just thought
of this morning that pooped on it and
then put it in a script
oh we're gonna carve out a section of
this deposit you know what I mean the
sets were cool and the stylization of
the film was really cool the costumes
and it all looked very cool very Grinchy
I guess very you know how cat mat should
look it looks super cool I loved it I
loved it
it started off before cat showed up
everything was fine in my note so I was
like oh it's just jack and then I wrote
Oh No
Oh Jack no hard to make him not funny I
think and they did it with such briefs
and ease hmm easy breezy beautiful
gesture fire yeah that's not funny just
yelling fire done into someone's face as
a boss isn't funny up then I wrote Oh
God
alec baldwin is in this Oh God how did
Alec Baldwin weasel his way into what is
happening so the story is about this
single mother who's dating Alec Baldwin
and she has two children the children
always make a mess of that house and
she's going to get fired if the party
she's throwing tonight for her job is it
like a spotless spick-and-span
clean party and so she has to leave for
the day and all of this stuff happens
with Kat and the kids make a mess of the
house and it's like about getting the
house clean the game and you know
capturing their dog that ran away it's a
mess of a story it's terrible but Alec
Baldwin's character wants the son of the
mother to go to military school because
he's a little brat and he makes a mess
of everything and he's very immature he
does the opposite of what everyone tells
him to do great cool cool cool
we're supposed to be like pitted against
Alec Baldwin's character and this which
let's be honest isn't hard to do but
it's so funny because he's like I you
should go to military school and
everyone's like wow that's crazy and I'm
like yeah that's one rat regardless if
it's the mom instead of having a fight
at one point and the son goes sometimes
I wish I had a different mom and the mom
fires back yeah well sometimes I wish
the same thing whoa brutal son fire
shots just flying everywhere damn shit I
wrote this is really cute so far I think
it might be Mike Meyers that makes this
movie bad so far it's good
[Laughter]
then he comes in dad what the nothing
about him is funny
his physical humor not funny his jokes
not funny the way he's delivering the
lines not funny the makeup atrocious
every he's just what is happening here
what is going on what what what are you
doing
oh he coughed up a hairball that's
hilarious actually right before I
started filming this mic at Wendy's in
fact did cough up a hairball and it
wasn't funny and it was just it was
funnier than the movie should have cast
Wendy she's internet famous for eating
pancakes
so she there's a big musical number when
he enters and it's all about having fun
the song is about having fun and I
browned through the whole thing I was it
actively angered me to watch this
musical number of a giant talking cat
about having fun the I it's very own
brand for me to like something like that
and I surround through the entire thing
you guys so many fart and poop and burp
jokes throughout all of this you know I
would actually like to formally
apologize to the word joke for how I
used you just now mark and poop and Jill
i sorely misused you and it will not
happen again for the bottom of my heart
I'm sorry just wrote I wish this were
Shrek I think one thing to show up
they're not funny
they're not funny in big letters ever
nothing is funny anymore help and the
fish is the best actor the CGI fish the
best actor then he's a pinata for some
reason they're like hide and then he
sees that there's a giant cat pinata
eggs like you know what it's weirdly
sexual too like yeah they're doing a
bunch of like adult jokes adult humor in
this that's not what I mean I mean like
having this bigger adult size man cat
walking around with these kids and like
having kids hit him in the crotch
that's a pinata like stuff like it's
just it's it's very weirdly on the verge
of being sexual I'm probably just
looking too deep into it because I was
sitting there just trying to find
anything to talk about
during this stupid movie every joke is
misery that's a fun one that I wrote fun
line you know how to tell when a movie
is bad it's when Paris Hilton shows up
and you're like oh okay
there's something of note I just
suddenly in the middle of watching this
film had a brilliant idea that I had to
write down and it's just four words I
can dip hats Wow you know what it'll
bring joy to some viewers after a
10-minute misery review is um I can
different different pasts
what was that Universal Studios call
what was that
they're on a roller coaster and the Sun
is like this is like a roller coaster
and he's like just like the ones that
Universal Studios and he pulls out two
tickets to Universal Studios what
surprised myself a little with how angry
I wrote it's almost impossible how
shitty it is it's almost impossible but
they did it okay so Rob Walker says
Myers wanted out and the studio held him
to the contract game rumor is he made it
extra awful just to bring the project
down he trolled it and won it was
miserable I hope that's the case
that makes it better in my mind's
because I really like Mike Myers and I
did not really like this I I hated this
maybe I hated it I love cats I love hats
this was just a swing and a Miss you
know thank you so much for watching this
terrible moment in my life cue I can hat
he wasn't hats to be put on you just
Santa hat do you do you like that now
just a witch attack with an ice cream
wig it's a little culturally insensitive
that's what this is it's a blonde cat
wig really nice bike a million trees
back
[Music]
[Applause]
you